[Music]
hey what's up everybody today we got a
new TV spot trailer for ant-man and the
wasp it's short and sweet but it's
getting us excited to see the movie when
it comes out and it's also getting us
excited about Avengers 4 let's take a
look everything you know everything
you've experienced has all led to this
is that my desk yeah why do I have such
a small desk well cuz you weren't that
one lurch isn't that soon as you lose I
was under house arrest yeah guys oh come
on we got to focus on July 6
this is garbage I got it at a rummage
sale ant-man and the loss get tickets
tomorrow so it starts off by recapping
some of the scenes from Avengers
infinity war as it's recapping these
scenes you hear the narrator say
everything you know everything you've
experienced has all led up to this
obviously this is a joke and they're
obviously doing a play on the trailers
that they released for infinity war
before it came out because the next
scene after they say it's all been
leading up to this is a scene where
Scott Lang jokes about how small his
desk is but there is a lot of truth to
what the narrator is saying everything
has in fact been leading up to fan OHS
to snap and Avengers infinity war where
he wipes out half the universe and now
it's led to how did the Avengers undo it
and Avengers for a bunch of people from
Marvel have already come out and said
that the movie will be of major
significance leading up to and in
Avengers 4 and everybody highly believes
that what they are referring to is
time-travel ant-man and the wasp will
heavily explore the quantum realm and it
is believed that they will figure out
time travel in this movie so it actually
all has been leading up to this figuring
out a way to defeat Thanos after we get
past the infinity war scenes all the new
scenes that take place are in this
office and most of it is just jokes
because ant-man of the wasp is supposed
to be a pretty funny movie and a
light-hearted movie which is good
because Avengers infinity war was pretty
intense
one thing that was mentioned in the
trailer is that Scott Lang was on house
arrest if you're unfamiliar with this
after the events of civil war both Scott
Lang or ant-man and Clinton Barton or
Hawkeye both took plea deals so they
could be with their family and in turn
they were both put on house arrest and
again the rest of it is just jokes and
some action Clips turn in there as well
but all that makes us really excited to
see ant-man and the wasp in just a few
short weeks so what are you most excited
about to see when ant-man and the wasp
comes out let me know your thoughts in
the comments below click the thumbs up
button if you enjoyed this video and as
always be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you can stay up to date on
ant-man on the wasp Avengers for Marvel
DC and all things superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]